>>> LIZ CHENEY DRAWING A LINE IN
THE SAND.
THE WYOMG CONGRESSWOMAN WHO
JUST LOST HER PRIMARY BID FOR
RE-ELECTION WAS ASKED A VERY
SPECIFIC POINTED QUESTION
YESTERDAY AT THE TEXAS TRIBUNE
FESTIVAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WILL YOU REMAIN A REPUBLICAN
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE NEXT ELECTION?
>> I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE DONALD
TRUMP IF HE'S THE CANDIDATE MAKE
SURE HE'S NOT THE NOMINEE, AND
IF HE IS THE NOMINEE I'LL NOT BE
A REPUBLICAN.
>> CHENEY ALSO SAID SHE'LL
CAMPAIGN FOR DEMOCRATS TO ENSURE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES WHO
PROMOTED ELECTION LIES DO NOT
GET ELECTED.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THIS
ALICE STEWART AND MARIA CAR
DONA.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH ME
THIS EVENING.
ALICE, TO YOU FIRST.
WE JUST HEARD THERE THAT PRETTY
FORCEFUL STATEMENT FROM LIZ
CHENEY.
IF SHE LEAVES THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHERE DO YOU THINK SHE
ENDS UP, AND DO YOU THINK
REPUBLICANS CARE?
>> LOOK, PRIVATELY THERE ARE A
LOT OF REPUBLICANS THAT SUPPORT
WHAT SHE'S DOING IN TERMS OF
STANDING UP FOR DEFENDING
FREEDOM, PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER AND UPHOLDING THE RULE OF
LAW.
BUT PUBLICLY, MANY OF THEM ARE
SAYING DON'T LET THE DOOR HIT
YOU ON THE WAY OUT.
THEY SAY SHE HAS CAUSED TOO MUCH
ATTENTION TO HER FRUSTRATION
WITH DONALD TRUMP AND WHAT HE'S
DONE WITH JANUARY 6th, AND THEY
ARE HAPPY TO SEE HER LEAVE.
I TALKED WITH HER CAMP, AND THEY
TELL ME SHE DOESN'T REALLY WANT
TO LEAVE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
BUT IF HE'S THE NOMINEE SHE HAS
NO CHOICE.
SHE WOULD VIEW DONALD TRUMP AS
THE NOMINEE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN 2024 AS THE PARTY IS
MORE OF A CULTIVE PERSONALITY AS
OPPOSED TO A PARTY OF PRINCIPLE.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO MOVING
FORWARD IS GET BACK TO THE
PRINCIPLES AND FOCUS ON WHAT
VOTERS CARE ABOUT WHICH IS THE
ECONOMY, INFLATION AND CRIME.
WE DON'T NEED TO CONTINUE TO
CARRY WATER ON DONALD TRUMP FOR
HIS PAST GRIEVANCES ON THE
ELECTION HE CLEARLY LOST.
>> MARIA, AS CLOSELY AS LIZ
CHENEY HAS WORKED WITH DEMOCRATS
ON THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE, IT
WOULD BE STUNNING TO SEE HER ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL CAMPAIGNING
FOR DEMOCRATS.
DO YOU THINK SHE'D BE WELCOMED
WITH OPEN ARMS?
>> I THINK SHE WOULD BE BECAUSE,
ALEX, ONE OF THE MOST TRAGIC
THINGS ABOUT ALL OF THIS IS THAT
LIZ CHENEY IS ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS THAT
EXISTS TODAY.
I MEAN, HER NAME, HER HISTORY,
HER VOTING RECORD.
AND THE FACT THAT HER PARTY IS
PUNISHING HER FOR HER VALUES,
FOR PUTTING COUNTRY AND
DEMOCRACY AND THE CONSTITUTION
BEFORE HER PARTY AND HER
POLITICS TO ME IS JUST
ASTOUNDING.
AND I REALLY DO THINK THAT WHAT
SHE SAID SHOULD BE UNDERSCORED,
THAT IT DEMONSTRATES JUST HOW
SICK THE PARTY IS AND HOW
COMPLETELY DEVIATED FROM WHAT
ALICE SAYS ARE THE PARTY'S
VALUES, PRINCIPLES.
BECAUSE AS MUCH AS MY DEAR
FRIEND ALICE WANTS HER PARTY FOR
THAT TO BE THE FOCUS, IT'S NOT.
THE FOCUS IS ON ELECTION
DENIERS.
SO LIZ CHENEY IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO SAY SHE DOES NOT WANT
TRUMP TO BE RE-ELECTED AGAIN.
AS A DEMOCRAT I AGREE.
HE'S A DANGER TO OUR DEMOCRACY,
AND I DO THINK SHE'LL BE
ABSOLUTELY WELCOMED FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE TO EMPHASIZE
THIS HUGE THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
THAT WOULD POSE GIVING CONTROL
OVER TO REPUBLICANS WHO MANY OF
THEM ARE ELECTION DENIERS.
>> AND ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP TO
WHAT MARIA SAID.
ELECTION DENIERS IN LARGE PART
ARE PEOPLE WE HAVE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEES IN THESE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS.
I THINK THIS NOVEMBER WILL BE A
BIG TEST FOR THE PARTY IF THESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE FINE WITH
JANUARY 6th AND HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH THE WAY ELECTIONS ARE RUN,
IF THEY LOSE IN NOVEMBER, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY NEEDS TO
REALIZE WE NEED TO DO AWAY WITH
THAT WING OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND PUT PEOPLE THAT ARE
CERTAINLY MORE MODERATE AND
FOCUSED ON DIFFERENT ISSUES IN
2024.
>> OF COURSE IN THE MID-TERMS
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ELECTION
DENIERS WHO ARE RUNNING.
WE HAVE A NEW POLL WITH JUST 44
DAYS TO GO UNTIL THE ELECTION,
THIS POLL FROM CBS SHOWING 7 IN
10 WOMEN SAY THAT A CANDIDATE
MUST AGREE WITH THEM ON -- MUST
AGREE WITH THEM ON ABORTION
ISSUES TO GET THEIR VOTE OR
AGREE WITH THEM IN GENERAL TO
GET THEIR VOTE ESPECIALLY FOR
WOMEN WHO WANT ABORTION TO BE
LEGAL.
ALICE, HOW MUCH DO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES NEED TO BE WORRYING
ABOUT WOMEN VOTERS RIGHT NOW?
>> BASED ON WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND
TWO TIMES WHEN THE ELECTION WAS
ON THE BALLOT ONE WAS ON THE
AMENDMENT AND ANOTHER NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN RAN ON THE ISSUE.
REPUBLICANS NEEDS TO REALIZE
ABORTION HAS PROVED TO BE A
MOTIVATOR FOR WOMEN AND EVEN
SOME MEN AND UNDECIDED VOTERS.
BUT IT KEY HERE IS TO SHIFT THE
FOCUS OF THE ELECTION TO -- TO
INFLATION, TO THE ECONOMY, AND
TO IMMIGRATION.
ABORTION IS CERTAINLY A DRIVER,
BUT IT'S ALWAYS THE ECONOMY THAT
REALLY TURNS OUT VOTERS.
AND FROM A MESSAGING STANDPOINT,
WHICH MARIA AND I BOTH DO,
CANDIDATES NEED TO FOCUS ON
MESSAGING THEIR SERVICE AND WHAT
THEY PLAN TO DO AS A WAY TO
IMPROVE THE ECONOMY AND
CERTAINLY WORK ON INFLATION.
>> ABORTION OF COURSE CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD ALL THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
EMPHASIZING.
MARIA, I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
ANOTHER POLL ALSO FROM CBS AND
UGOV SHOWING THAT BY A 2-1
MARGIN VOTERS BELIEVE THAT A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS WOULD LEAD
TO WOMEN GETTING FEWER RIGHTS
AND FREEDOMS THAN THEY HAVE NOW.
SO HOW MUCH MORE CONFIDENT DO
YOU BELIEVE DEMOCRATS ARE
FEELING RIGHT NOW, AGAIN, WITH
JUST 44 DAYS TO GO?
>> WELL, WE'RE CERTAINLY FEELING
CONFIDENT THAT ABORTION IS GOING
TO PUT FRONT AND CENTER THE
MESSAGE YOU JUST MENTIONED,
WHICH IS IT'S NOT JUST ABORTION.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS A PARTY THAT
DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT WOMEN ARE
EQUAL TO MEN, THAT DOES NOT
BELIEVE WOMEN SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
RIGHTS TO MEN, THAT DOES NOT
BELIEVE WOMEN SHOULD HAVE THE
FREEDOM, THE PRIVACY, THE
LIBERTY TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
OUR OWN BODIES AND OUR OWN
REPRODUCTIVE FUTURES.
THAT SHOULD BE DAMNING, PERIOD.
AND SO WHAT I BELIEVE DEMOCRATS
ARE LOOKING AT IS TO MOBILIZE
AND ENERGIZE WOMEN VOTERS ACROSS
THE BOARD, NOT JUST DEMOCRATS
BUT INDEPENDENT WOMEN, EVEN
REPUBLICAN WOMEN WHO BELIEVE,
AGAIN, THAT PUTTING REPUBLICANS
IN POWER IS A HUGE DANGER TO THE
FUTURE OF THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN,
THE FUTURE OF DEMOCRACY, THE
FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
ALEX, THERE IS A REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN MICHIGAN THAT HAS
SAID THAT GIVING WOMEN THE RIGHT
TO VOTE WAS A MISTAKE.
THIS, I THINK, JUST IT REALLY
GIVES YOU THE PICTURE OF A
PARTY, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT
IS SPECTACULARLY OUT OF TOUCH
WITH WHERE THIS COUNTRY IS AND
WHERE THIS COUNTRY SHOULD BE
GOING IN THE FUTURE.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN LIGHT OF THIS NEW
EXCERPT WE'VE GOT FROM MAGGIE
HABERMAN WHO'S PUTTING OUT ONE
OF THE MOST HIGHLY ANTICIPATED
BOOKS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP SINCE
HE LEFT OFFICE.
HABERMAN SAYS SHE HAD THREE
TWO-HOUR INTERVIEWS WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
AND IN THOSE INTERVIEWS, IN ONE
OF THEM AT LEAST HE CALLED HER
HIS PSYCHIATRIST.
AND SHE TALKS ABOUT A
CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD WITH
MIKE PENCE AHEAD OF THE JANUARY
6th RIOTS, AND THIS IS WHAT HE
TOLD MIKE PENCE.
MIKE, YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO BE
THOMAS JEFFERSON OR YOU CAN BE
MIKE PENCE, TRUMP TOLD HABERMAN,
REPORTING AN INACCURATE
COMPARISON TO THE ELECTION OF
1800.
AND, QUOTE, HE CHOSE TO BE MIKE
PENCE.
SO, ALICE, DO YOU THINK THAT
MIKE PENCE IS OFFERING
REPUBLICANS A VERSION OF THE
PARTY THAT THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
AND A POTENTIAL CANDIDATE THAT
THEY COULD BE INTERESTED IN
2024?
>> LET ME JUST SAY THANK GOD
MIKE PENCE WAS MIKE PENCE ON
JANUARY 6th AND DID WHAT HE
COULD TO HELP CERTIFY THE
ELECTION.
BUT, LOOK, THE GOOD THING IS GOP
HAS A DEEP BENCH RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE SEVERAL CANDIDATES THAT
ARE ALREADY TESTING THE WATERS
AND GOING OUT TO THESE EARLY
STATES, AND WE HAVE A GOOD
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
GOOD, VIABLE CANDIDATES.
MIKE PENCE, WE CERTAINLY HAVE
DeSANTIS.
WE HAVE TOM COTTON.
WE HAVE TIM SCOTT, SEVERAL
PEOPLE.
SO WHETHER IT'S MIKE PENCE OR
ANY OF THESE OTHERS, I AM
ENCOURAGED TO KNOW THAT THE GOP
HAS SEVERAL OTHER OPTIONS THAN
DONALD TRUMP TO CHOOSE FROM.
>> I WANT TO PLAY A LITTLE BIT
OF SOUND FROM REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN NANCY MASE.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID TO SAY
EARLIER TODAY ON "MEET THE
PRESS."
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> DO YOU EXPECT AN IMPEACHMENT
VOTE AGAINST PRESIDENT BIDEN IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER THE HOUSE?
>> I BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON REPUBLICANS TO HAVE
THAT VOTE, TO PUT THAT
LEGISLATION FORWARD AND TO HAVE
THAT VOTE.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
SOME FOLKS ARE CONSIDERING.
>> WOW.
>> MARIA, FIRST OF ALL, WHAT
WOULD THEY IMPEACH HIM FOR, AND
HOW LIKELY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> THEY WOULD IMPEACH HIM FOR
BEING A DEMOCRAT.
REALLY THERE IS NO OTHER --
>> RETRIBUTION.
>> RIGHT, RETRIBUTION, GETTING
BACK AT HIM FOR EVERYTHING THAT
HE AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
FOCUSED ON IN TERMS OF MAKING
DONALD TRUMP ACCOUNTABLE, MAKING
THE REPUBLICANS ACCOUNTABLE, FOR
GETTING US SO CLOSE TO LOSING
OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND FOR THEM NOT CARING, NOT
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT, NOT
PUTTING TRUMP TO THE SIDE,
PUTTING HIMDYING CONTINUE TO PUT
HIM FRONT AND CENTER.
I THINK THAT SOUND SHOULD
TERRIFY ALL OF US.
AND THERE IS ALREADY
LEGISLATION, RIGHT, THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE FILED TO TRY TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN IF REPUBLICANS
TAKE OVER.
AND I THINK IT UNDERSCORES THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE ZERO
SOLUTIONS ON THE THINGS THAT
THEY SAY SHOULD BE FRONT AND
CENTER LIKE MY FRIEND ALEX SAYS
INFLATION SHOULD BE FRONT AND
CENTER, THE ECONOMY.
AND YES, IT IS.
AND GUESS WHO HAS ACTUALLY DONE
THINGS TO HELP THE ECONOMY, HELP
INFLATION, THE DEMOCRATS AND JOE
BIDEN WITH ZERO HELP FROM THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY BANKRUPT OF
IDEAS TO SOLVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND MORE THAN THAT THEY
REPRESENT THE TREMENDOUS DANGER
TO DEMOCRACY WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> YEAH, THEY'VE CERTAINLY BEEN
TELEGRAPHING WHAT THEY PLAN TO
DO IF THEY TAKE BACK THE HOUSE,
NOT JUST IMPEACHMENT BUT D